on coved his country's figures are among
the world's worst
now recorded conversations with donald
trump
indicate that long before the virus took
hold in the united states
he knew the extent of the danger and
concealed it
in a series of calls with the journalist
paul woodward the president told how
deadly the virus was
and how he wanted to play it down it
goes through air bob that's always
tougher than the touch you know the
touch you don't have to touch things
right but the air
you just breathe the air and that's how
it's uh passed
and so that's a very tricky one that's a
very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flus
i wanted to always play it down i still
like playing it down
yes because i don't want to create a
panic
the president's concerns in private
contrasts with an
optimistic tone in public at a news
conference
he was asked why the fact is i'm a
cheerleader for this country i love our
country
and i don't want people to be frightened
i don't want to create panic as you say
and certainly i'm not going to drive
this country or the world into a frenzy
his opponent in the u.s election race
said the president had
lied on coronavirus and cost lives
it was a life and death betrayal of the
american people experts say
that if he'd acted just just one week
sooner 36 000 people would have been
saved
if he acted two weeks sooner back in
march 54
000 lives would have been spared in
march and april alone
the book that contains the revelations
also carries the views of senior
colleagues
who call the president dangerous unfit
and with no moral compass it is a
damning critique
questions over covet concealment and its
consequences
are among the most damning of all james
matthews
sky news washington